[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
american women today have less freedom
than their mothers abortion violence is
the number one killer of children in
america until today the supreme court
overturns roe v wade and johnny depp and
amber heard's teams are back in court
does amber heard plan to appeal plus
i've been informed that you've reached a
verdict is that correct
a verdict is handed down in the candy
the dog civil trial and later from
alleged child grooming to unsafe living
conditions we take a closer look at
allegations against actor ezra miller
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer a
monumental ruling by the supreme court
of the united states as roe versus wade
is overturned on friday back in 1973 roe
v wade was a landmark scotus decision
ruling it was a woman's choice whether
to have an abortion but on friday
supreme court justices overturned that
ruling meaning women no longer have a
federal constitutional right to abortion
from here abortion rights will be
decided by each individual state unless
congress intervenes right now nearly
half of the states have abortion bans
the ruling came from a split decision
with justices nominated by republican
presidents holding the scotus majority
justice samuel alito wrote in part quote
roe was egregiously wrong from the start
its reasoning was exceptionally weak and
the decision had damaging consequences
in a joint dissenting opinion justices
stephen breyer sona mayor and elena
kagan wrote in part quote with sorrow
for this court but more for the many
millions of american women who have
today lost a fundamental constitutional
protection we dissent now all of this
comes weeks after politico released a
draft opinion showing the court voted to
overturn the ruling
house speaker nancy pelosi said
republicans are on a crusade to
criminalize health freedom for women
what this means to women is such an
insult
it's a slap in the face to women about
using their own judgment
to make their own decisions
about their reproductive freedom
this is deadly serious
but we are not going to let this pass
a woman's right to choose
reproductive freedom is on the ballot in
november
we cannot allow them
to take charge so that they can
institute their goal
which is to criminalize
reproductive freedom
we also heard from republican leaders
who praised the scotus ruling
speaker pelosi just lectured us she said
guns are the number one killer of
children in america that's not true
abortion violence is the number one
killer of children in america until
today there's no right to abortion in
the constitution and thankfully the
supreme court finally said that
decisively thanks be to god
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and former prosecutor bernarda villalone
it's great to see you both bernard i'll
start with you after nearly a half a
century roe v wade has been overturned
what is your reaction to a really
monumental ruling
jesse today the supreme court issued a
devastating blow to us women are us
women are reproductive rights it's funny
because i'm looking at the supreme court
and actually the supreme court is equal
justice under the law and that is
exactly the opposite that the u.s
supreme court issued today when they
determined that a right that i was born
into no longer exists that it shouldn't
have existed from the very beginning and
that being the right to choose on
whether a person wants to have an
abortion well terry everybody's
wondering what's going to happen next so
it's up to the states to decide but what
could those decisions look like i mean
do you expect to see women flooding to
states where abortion is legal
every state is going to make their own
laws and it will be in accordance with
that legislative agenda some of the
conservative states are going to ban or
severely limit access to abortion
liberal states will probably grant women
access in accordance with roe v wade
which is saying that abortions are going
to be restricted only after the
viability which is the first trimester
and so i do think we will see women
traveling from state to state this is
going to make it very difficult for
women who don't have the economic means
to do that and so it's not fair for
those women who won't be able to make
their own decisions and have that choice
so we're going to see a lot of different
events in different states based on how
that state makes their laws right and a
separate issue about whether or not
congress will actually codify law
regarding abortion rights as well still
ahead on long crime daily a verdict is
reached in the candy the dog trial out
of florida but first johnny depp versus
amber heard the latest from the fairfax
county courthouse
[Music]
welcome back everybody nearly one month
after the verdict johnny depp and amber
heard's teams are back in court long
crime's angenette levy joins us now from
the fairfax county courthouse with a
breakdown of friday's hearing
this hearing was largely a formality and
judge penny asked karate who oversaw
this case was no nonsense as usual
cameras were not allowed inside the
courtroom for the hearing but the
hearing was open to the public amber
heard's attorney elaine bredehoff told
judge ask karate that she wanted to file
motions and have a hearing but the judge
told her i've had this case for 18
months and we had a six week trial i'm
not having a hearing bretta hoft also
wanted to address the fact that amber
heard has to post a suspension bond
which is the judgment awarded to depp of
10.35 million dollars plus six percent
interest annually in order to appeal
judge ask karate told her that is the
procedure meanwhile johnny depp's team
posted an exhibit with the judgment
outlining why they object to the
judgment against depp for statements
made by his lawyer adam waldman to the
daily mail there are several bullet
points in the exhibit including the fact
that depp feels the 2 million award was
excessive and that finding depth liable
was contrary to the facts and the law
meanwhile there were some supporters for
johnny depp in court for the hearing my
thoughts on today's hearing
were
kind of the way i felt during the whole
trial itself is that i feel like amber
heard's attorney elaine bredehoff was
still trying to get
things
and argue a little bit with the judge
wherever she could
i think judge penny was just done and
she wasn't having it um today following
the judgment was basically all they were
here to do um and so i think that you
know
it was a
it was pretty simple and easy and
straightforward other than miss bredhoff
trying to get
a little thing a few things here and
there i approached elaine brettelhoff
the lead attorney for amber heard and
asked her whether she would speak with
us on camera and if she had anything to
say she said no but amber heard
spokesperson issued a statement saying
as stated in thursday's congressional
hearings you don't ask for a pardon if
you are innocent and you don't decline
to appeal if you know that you are right
amber heard has 30 days to post that
suspension bond and file an appeal for
law and crime daily i'm angenette levy
all right so terry a lot of people
thought that with the verdict it was
done so is it normal to have a hearing
like this after a verdict is handed down
what's normal jesse is to have a hearing
where you are actually entering the
judgment so you get the verdict and it
does take time to draft that judgment
usually the prevailing party drafts the
judgment and so judge askaratti said to
ben draft the judgment show it to
opposing counsel make sure you agree on
the wording come back on june 4th and i
will enter that judgment now in the
meantime of course they could have had
discussions about settlement if they
wanted to turns out there will be no
settlement and in fact just the opposite
we know for a fact that amber heard is
going to appeal just 30 days to file
that
notice of appeal and then you know it'll
be out of ascara's hands and it'll go to
another court but yeah so it's normal to
have a hearing but just to enter the
judgment most other things aren't done
and i think that's why the judge was
impatient all right well let's talk
about that appeal so what does this all
mean bernarda in terms of a potential
appeal for amber heard and whether or
not she'll have a successful appeal
well the question will be is whether she
has the money to pay these attorneys for
an appeal or for a new trial if the
appeal were to be granted all of this
takes time it takes patience and it
takes a lot of money i can tell you just
ordering the transcripts on a daily
basis you're talking about pages that
cost about three dollars per page and we
know that there were hundreds of hours
of testimony now will an appeal be
granted in this case i highly doubt it
but hey
today so many surprises you just never
know
that's a good point you just never know
and i think at a site you know it's so
expensive filing these lawsuits which
might be one of the reasons why johnny
depp decided hey i'm not going to forgo
or with you know waive my right to the
monetary judgment he's got lawyers to
pay so it's something to think about
there all right coming up on long crime
daily actor ezra miller faces multiple
accusations including that he groomed a
teenager plus a verdict is handed down
in the candy the dog civil trial
[Music]
welcome back closing arguments are
presented and a verdict is handed down
in the so-called candy the dog civil
trial out in florida rodney jacobson
is seeking justice for candy after his
beloved terrier pit bull mix was shot
and killed by zac dieterle the lawsuit
stems from an incident in 2016 at dieter
lee's family property where jacobson
stored his boat now dieterly says as he
walked towards jacobson candy snarled
and snapped at him in what he says was
an attack stance he testified he tried
to stop candy by kicking rocks at her
and kicking the dog but says he feared
for his life when he pulled out his gun
and shot her jacobson says candy had no
history of aggression deterley wasn't
charged because local officials say he
was within his rights to use deadly
force and he had a permit to carry the
weapon before the case made it to the
jury attorneys on both sides made one
final plea thursday jacobson's attorney
used deterly's own words to argue for
his client
still an utter disbelief had what had
just transpired
turns to mr deeterley and says did you
just shoot my dog
defend his own admission on the stand
you're damn right i did
i tried to tell you about how remorseful
he was
yet immediately after the incident
he called mr jacobson an effing moron
i'm going to pull back the language
we've already heard it enough in this
courtroom
effin moron
gd idiot
brandishing the firearm at him
does that sound like somebody who's
truly remorseful
[Music]
you're damn right i did
that's not something you say to someone
right after you shoot their dog even if
you are in
fear for your life
from there dieterle's attorney presented
his side's closing argument arguing his
client believed he was going to be hurt
by candy and in turn says he had no
other option but to shoot the dog
even despite the efforts of mr dietly to
try to kick the dog away from it after
it made several passes at him after he
couldn't back up anymore because he
risked falling into a mud pit
after he
yelled to mr jacobson after he had
already tried all those other things to
keep the dog away from him while mr
jacobson stood silent doing nothing
that mr deiterly had to take out his gun
and shoot the dog otherwise he risked
injury
mr tympanic like to point out the fact
that mr deadly was not bitten
he had no bite marks his clothes weren't
torn up with the dog's teeth
thankfully that is true
but had mr deedly fallen in the mud pit
that was directly behind him
it could be a totally different story
the jury handed down the verdict friday
afternoon after just two hours of
deliberating
i've been informed that you've reached a
verdict is that correct
rodney m jacobson plaintiff versus
zachary kate early
and spring release llc a florida limited
liability company
verdict preliminary questions was mr
dearly justified in using deadly force
against the dog in self-defense
yes
okay so bernardo let's start with those
closing arguments we just watched two
very different styles two completely
different narratives what did you make
of it
two different styles of course and two
different narratives if they were the
same narrative it wouldn't be a trial
but what i can tell you from the
snippets that we saw is that both sides
use the best facts that they had in
order to create a story for the jury and
i think when it all came down to is that
you can't get past the fact that yes
this is a dog yes this is an animal but
it's a dog that is capable of causing
injury immediately
immediate injury have you ever been
chased down the street by a dog you are
scared so you just never know what could
happen so that's why i'm not surprised
at the verdict from this jury terry what
about you i mean this was a lot for the
jury to consider do you think the jury
based on everything you've seen in this
case and all the evidence in both the
plaintiff and the defendant taking the
stand is this the correct verdict
you know what jesse i watched this case
very closely yes it is the correct
verdict it's a tough situation obviously
no one wants to hear about a dog being
shot but the jury focused on two factual
issues was candy aggressive and whether
or not he was afraid for his life as to
the first issue several witnesses
testified that yes candy was aggressive
they saw her snarling at other people
and they in fact were in here as well
and then deterly got on the stand he was
an excellent witness he testified that
he was fear of his life he was surprised
he saw candy coming at him tried to back
up as you mentioned he kicked dirt first
so he didn't shoot immediately then he
actually made contact with the dog when
he kicked her and he hit her head so he
ended up shooting her only as a last
resort and he was able to convince that
jury that he only shot because he was
afraid for his life he didn't shoot
after the dog after it ran away he only
shot the dog trying to stop it from
attacking him so i think it was the
right decision all in all and i think
the jury came down quickly with that
decision because the facts were pointing
to that direction well i will tell you
i'm surprised by both you terry and
bernardo because a lot of our analysts
who i spoke to completely disagreed and
thought that rodney jacobson was going
to win so this seems like it's going to
be a verdict that will have a lot of
people divided in the time to come
well starting next week long crime is
going to be covering a new cat new case
out of ozark county missouri the bench
trial of rebecca rood a woman accused of
killing and dismembering her daughter
savannah leckie in 2017. savannah who
had autism was adopted at birth by tamil
and david leckie in minnesota and after
the leckies separated savannah moved to
missouri to live with her biological
mother rude on her theodosia area farm
now 11 months later rude reported her
daughter missing on july 20th 2017 and
it wasn't until later that her remains
were discovered burned on rood's
property the same day law enforcement
discovered the remains rude married her
boyfriend and co-defendant robert pete
both of them have been charged with
first-degree murder second-degree murder
child abuse resulting in death tampering
with evidence and abandonment of a
corpse opening statements are slated to
begin monday morning and you can follow
long crime for gavel to gavel coverage
when we come back actor ezra miller
under fire we take a closer look at the
reports that are underway
welcome back everybody actor ezra miller
is making headlines for a slew of
bizarre reports involving unsafe living
conditions grooming teenagers and a
one-year-old child child who put a
bullet in their mouth
miller first made headlines several
weeks ago for back-to-back arrests in
hawaii for causing a disturbance at a
karaoke bar and later for throwing a
chair
this week rolling stone released a
report saying miller was housing a young
mullet mother and three children in
unsafe conditions at a secluded vermont
farm the report states that guns are
lying around the home including in the
living room where a one-year-old child
put a bullet in her mouth
rolling stone also says that there's
heavy marijuana use at the home in front
of the children ranging in age from one
years old to five and at the same time
officials in north dakota sent out a
protective order against miller who is
yet to be located by the court parents
there accused miller of grooming their
teenage daughter with cult-like behavior
and violence all right bernarda i'm not
even sure where to even begin here but
what sort of repercussions could miller
be facing here in light of all these
accusations
i'm waiting to hear when the department
of children and families are going to go
to the location and try to investigate
these allegations before it's too late
of course we never want to hear that
something has happened to a child or
that the police are running onto
someone's property for no reason at all
but we need to be careful because we
have all heard of those kids that have
died at young ages at the hands of
others who don't properly care for the
environment that the children are in
bernard let me just follow up with you
in a second how come they can't find
them
i don't understand how they can't find
him if the media can find him and uh
take pictures of him
that's a good point i mean terry look
how do you prove something like unsafe
living conditions for a child or even
grooming a teenager these are not
accusations that we hear typically and
not amount to charges that we we've
heard typically we've kind of heard a
little bit with galen maxwell
absolutely in fact i was going to
mention that with the unsanitary
conditions there's all kinds of evidence
that can be presented you can show that
there are you know a situation where the
house isn't kept clean where you're not
getting food where there's physical
abuse even bruises or broken bones or
there's emotional abuse so any type of
evidence where there is a condition that
is not safe for that child it could be a
range of things and you know as far as
grooming is concerned like you said just
we saw that in the billy maxwell case
that is actually defined as establishing
a relationship with that child in order
to promote some sort of sexual activity
and it could be grooming with the child
it could be grooming with the family
which it does sound like might be
occurring here and it takes place by
lowering that child's inhibitions you
try to make a friend with that child you
try to give them gifts you do all of
these things that the child thinks that
you are becoming close to them and that
you're a friend and that they will trust
you so that's what they'd have to prove
they probably use an expert in the case
if this case is actually brought to show
that all of those things have been
occurring so we'll see what happens we
will i mean these are disturbing
allegations against this man so we'll
see what happens bernarda terry thank
you so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you